[Music]
hello everyone welcome to democratizing
data with bigquery and data mesh I'm
Stuart moncata group product manager and
Google Cloud's data analytics team and
I'm vikas Kumar head of data AIML
architecture at CNA insurance
today we're going to be learning about
data Transformations using Google's data
cloud with a data mesh architecture in
the first part of the session I'll
provide a little bit of context on some
of the challenges organizations are
facing and how Google's data Cloud can
be used to address those challenges and
in the second part because will bring it
to life with the real example of their
data transformation and how they were
able to democratize data we're going to
cover things like transformation
strategy and journey
before and after architecture as well as
cultural and organizational changes
let's do it let's go
now let's start with setting the context
a little bit
we're in a phase of uncertainty where
data and Innovation are more important
than ever we're well into year three of
the pandemic
we went from cheap capital and
Unstoppable growth to some of the
headlines you see here
supply chain challenges inflationists
Sky High markets are declining and
ultimately companies small and large are
being impacted teams are being asked to
do more with less
now on the more positive side the power
of data Ai and analytics it's undeniable
it's the reason why we're all here today
and it's a great tool to continue to
innovate while keeping costs under
control
however organizations really struggle to
get value out of their data and Ai and
actually very few organizations are able
to show measurable Financial benefits
from their data
now let's talk about why that's the case
at Google we're fortunate to work with a
lot of organizations and we get to learn
a lot from the customers that we work
with and really we're seeing three
themes as to why organizations struggle
to get value
number one data is big in multi-format
it's no longer just about structured
text Data increasingly it's images audio
video it's data from many different
sources and systems number two
data goes beyond SQL organizations are
looking to adopt new programming
Frameworks and new workloads like Ai and
ml as well as streaming and number three
data needs to reach everyone needs to go
beyond the data organization and impact
the entire company but also suppliers
partners and ultimately your end users
and your customers
now let's talk about what are the
characteristics of a modern data Cloud
that will allow you to get value from
all of your data across all workloads
and impact everyone
this is all done in a way that's highly
efficient security focused open and
compliant
now it really starts with being
serverless what does it mean to be truly
serverless it means you don't have to
worry about Hardware but also you don't
have to worry about clusters and VMS and
administration and optimization and you
get to focus on adding business value
bigquery serverless architecture takes
advantage of Google's technical
infrastructure that has been used for
over a decade to power Google's biggest
websites and applications
this is technology that has been tried
and tested and is used in some of the
biggest applications and websites in the
entire world
now serverless will get you up and
running quickly however organizations
are still looking for a platform that
has support for data of all types and at
all scales
and one theme that we're hearing
recently from a lot of our customers is
that they want to get the best of both
worlds and enjoy the benefits of a data
warehouse and a data Lake that's why
after years of investment we launched
Big Lake our storage engine that unifies
data warehouses and lakes
and enables fine-grained Access Control
across multi-clouds and open formats
this type of cross-cloud data analytics
openness is one of Google Cloud's
biggest differentiators and it aligns
with our vision of openness and
simplicity
okay so that was for Limitless data
let's now look at the workloads
organizations want to enable and unify a
lot of vendors here may propose a lot of
tools and processes for what we're about
to discuss our goal is to focus on
simplification
historically most data warehouses have
supported batch processing and some even
allow for micro batch however in today's
competitive environment speed is a
differentiator
with bigquery streaming API and
additional services like Pub sub data
flow and looker
organizations are able to get an
end-to-end real-time system with
real-time ingestion and real-time
analysis that unlocks new use cases like
anomaly detection recommendation engines
and overall continuous intelligence
now conversation on data and analytics
would not be complete without talking
about AI it's hard to come across an
organization that's not either using it
already or striving to use AI however
organizations are in very different
phases of their AI journey and we want
to meet them with the right tools at the
right time so for example you could have
a company that's looking to deploy the
first model
and looking to get started with machine
learning and with something like bqml
they're able to deploy an
enterprise-ready production model in a
few steps all within the bigquery
interface and have a model that's
trained predicting
in a very short amount of steps this
type of built-in simplicity
is so popular and so easy that it's been
adopted by over 80 percent of our top
customers
we also realize there could be an
organization that's a little bit further
in their AI Journey or looking to do
something very specific that's why in
those scenarios we have tools like
vertex AI where someone can deploy a
more advanced model or bring in models
from external notebooks
we've talked about data and workloads of
all types But ultimately we're doing all
of this to drive efficiency
enable better decision making and
provide better user experiences
so to see how Google's data Cloud can
reach across an organization we're going
to hand it over to vikas and hear about
their implementation of a data mesh
architecture and how they were able to
transform their organization thank you
Stuart and thank you for joining our
session I'm really really delighted to
be here I've been working on data for
quite some time now and one thing is
quite evident for me the data is at core
of every Enterprise Plus data AIML and
Cloud adoption has been on the rise
we've been on this journey for a couple
of years now and I thought it'll be good
to share our learning from this journey
what we have accomplished and where are
we going focus of today's session will
be how to decentralize data ecosystem by
leveraging data mesh architecture
let's talk about transformation Journey
itself most Transformations are
multifacet let's contextualize this into
a strategy I've highlighted in a simple
three strategy blogs first and foremost
it requires we hire right Talent put
them in right places second we have to
accelerate Cloud adoptions and
complement it with right set of tools
and Technologies governance and security
model has to be part of ecosystem last
but not least the important aspect that
everyone understand and work towards a
common goal and that common goal is how
to enable business to make data driven
decisions
to be successful with Cloud Journey we
have to augment transformation with
modernized work we have to make sure we
operate with product mindset agile in
nature going fully Cloud native means we
accelerate engineering practice enable
Cloud architecture develop code with CI
CD and devops is part of the culture we
must make sure that advanced analytics
and AIML capabilities are part of your
decision making process
one of the hardest part of this journey
and most organization and folks often
struggle is
they don't know where to start and how
to start having done this few times I've
wrapped up in a simple framework let's
unfold this framework with five easy
steps number one you formulate strategy
with your cloud provider in our case it
was Google we work with them for a
couple of months come up with a
strategic plan did a kick off
as part of this strategic plan you have
to Define what success look like to
prove the value and then make sure that
you socialize this word with your
Executives tag and business both make
sure you identify systems which will be
part of this transformation Journey once
you establish that you work towards
building platform to execute that
strategy
number five and perhaps the most
important you have to show the value
whether it's kpi metrics speed of the
data whatever it is
and degree and scale of this framework
has and may vary for depending on the
size of the organization but please feel
free to use it
let's talk about what we are
democratizing we are democratizing
platform data AIML on data data mesh
architecture we need to build Cloud
foundation so that data can travel from
left to right I truly believe the data
should be in the right hand side as soon
as it's generated from left hand side so
as a data leader so we have to make sure
we enable tools and Technologies to make
that happen because speed is the name of
the game and make sure you enable
and wrap business contacts with these
things
perhaps you should also make sure and
that's important aspect is is that you
make sure that you can handle variety of
data sources from this
furthermore we are unifying into a
common structure to reduce the
complexity of the data and we are
creating many data product one of the
most important one we are calling it
common data model and we are enabling
business to participate with us with a
simple framework of an aspect model to
implement data mesh architecture which
I'll show you in the third next Slide
the third component which really give
you uplift from this a data AIML and to
accelerate this further we are further
creating a data product we are calling
it model ready data set
now let's talk about cloud data platform
at high level and I'm sure you this
slide would resonate with many of you
let's focus on some specifics here we
are leveraging bigquery as data Lake in
past I have used object structures and
storage such as S3 and GCS as data Lake
over time I have learned that eventually
you end up moving this into Data
warehouses for data processing and
consumption purpose so why do that extra
hop hence we have eliminated that extra
layer and we are using bigquery as our
data Lake we are using some of the
advanced features from bigquery such as
instruction array without losing the
hierarchical of the data and it's
empowering our ecosystem for this
unified data set
we are creating many data product which
are highlighted in this slide now let's
talk about the bottom piece we are also
enabling some of the basic capabilities
in Cloud which is essential like data
metadata data catalog data quality
lineage and security and monitoring
which is part of our ecosystem
now let's talk about Legacy architecture
and I'm sure this will resonate with
many of you and you might have similar
in your ecosystem currently
when we built this we will build this
Based on data sources and we have
created multiple data Marts on top of
that data of frequency is batch Paradigm
basis data comes is daily weekly even
monthly for some use cases and we really
worked hard when we created this
and this led us to introduce the
complexity because we have builted data
Marts
introduces complexity such as data silos
and data duplications data governance
all of that is really hard because in
Legacy word today's standard wasn't a
priority
and in the absence of all of this even
for simple data consumptions we rely on
subject matter expert to consume the
data with us and that's a real problem
now let's fast forward and see how we
are solving this this next-gen data mesh
architecture
one of the things I have learned over
time in the cloud is that you have to
solve for the complex data structure
problem which get introduced by bringing
many data sources into the cloud our
focus should be how to make it easy to
consume for data consumers so they're
not struggling to join the data to build
complex code to understand the data we
are transforming for them and presenting
with a common model and unified data set
and really empowering them to just
consume the data because I truly believe
that data really gets value out of it
when it's easy to consume and
simplification is the differentiator and
is the main component in democratization
and some of the today's capabilities
which are essential are there such as
Discovery classification governance and
security and all that and furthermore we
have the flexibility and ability to
change the frequency of this on demand
now let's talk about how common model
are solving our cultural boundaries
problem
now you saw we are building
unified data model this data ecosystem
are really solving our cultural
boundaries problem as well
we are empowering business domain to
create their own data product and they
are self-sufficient to create their
workload in their respective domains in
case we feel the data can be shared with
other domains they have the provision
and that's how we are decentralizing
all of the data ecosystem and leveraging
data mesh architecture
now you saw how we are solving the
complex data structure problem with this
unified data sets these unified data set
are further enhancing and becoming a
backbone of our ecosystem and we are
further creating another data product on
top of that it's called Model ready data
set the purpose of this product is to
reduce the model building timeline easy
to discover and feature building for
data scientists so data scientist
Community can just focus on writing
model code rather than spending time on
discovering the data doing the data prep
which I know and many of you will
agree with me that their time goes 50 60
time goes just there so we are solving
for that
and all of this will be integrated with
vertex AI feature stores and bigquery
data Lake as well data Sciences has will
have ability to consume this directly
from over data Lake and they can build
badge and real-time production on top of
that
now let's talk about business value
right we are enabling data context with
data content
we are also unifying complex data
structure Problem by these common models
and data products you're also solving
time to Market Problem by bringing this
data into real time into these unified
data products we're also establishing
single source of Truth for the data
consumers
now let's talk about where we're going
next we are going with AIML prediction
model we're going to use more aim and in
our ecosystem we're going to enable
self-service platform capabilities
with single click
we're going to continue to advance and
Empower business domains so they can
create these workloads and we're going
to continue to integrate with
third-party ecosystem with SAS in Cloud
I hope you learned how we have
implemented data mesh architecture in
Google cloud and thank you for joining
our session today
[Music]